i have to remind you that
because under the request of state
department security
no one will be able to leave this room
until this press conference is over
and
everyone will be asked to stay seated as
mr rushdie leaves
we'll have to stay seated until he is
out of
the building
ready to start um
let me introduce you hi i'm clayton
boyce i'm president of the national
press club
and a news editor for the knight ritter
tribune news service
like to welcome you to the club for this
important press conference
with mr salman rushdie who met today
with
president clinton secretary of state
warren christopher
and national security adviser anthony
lake i'd like to introduce the people
at the head table and then turn the
microphone over to francis
de souza from the far right
is scott armstrong executive director of
the information
trust christopher hitchens british
journalist
carmel bedford of article 19.
she is international secretary of the
international rush t
defense committee ambassador nicholas
biliotis president of the association of
american publishers
and also co-chair of the international
russian defense
committee mr salman rushdie
francis d'souza was chair of the
international
rushdie defense committee and siobhan
dowd
director of the pan american center
freedom to write
committee and coordinator of the rushdie
defense committee
usa miss de souza
thank you very much indeed um i'm chair
of the international rushdie defense
committee
i think that all i want to say is that
we have spent many months
in trying to set up this meeting which
we consider probably to be the most
important one of our career so far
the russian defense committee has been
in existence since a few days after the
fatwa was first issued
in february in 1949 and 1989
the 14th of february 1989 since that
time it has taken a deliberately
political
view of the fatwa it's considered to
have been a political event and
therefore it needs political solutions
what we have done therefore in the last
18 months as a deliberate strategy and
policy
is to try to engage governments around
the world in supporting the campaign
and indeed coordinating with one another
to confront
this form this new form of religious
terrorism clearly as i'm sure all of you
will recognize that one of the most
important countries indeed the most
important country
to join in that campaign is the american
administration
and we are deeply honored and extremely
grateful and also very delighted
that today we achieved that aim
ladies and gentlemen mr salman rushdie
hello um thank you all for coming i know
it's it's just before thanksgiving and
you're not supposed to be here but so
thank you for
for making the time i i just want to
speak very briefly and then answer your
questions
um as i said in this in the statement
that you that you've been given i hope
um it was an extraordinary moment for me
to be in in the white house i i arrived
and
was met by mr lake and told him
how excited i was to be there and he
said well hang on because it's going to
get a little more exciting
because i had not known until that
moment that the president would be
available
i then walked with him um across the way
into the
old executive building and and was able
to meet with the president
there for four or five minutes um
the thing that i must say really struck
me
was that apart from the the issues of
principle and the
the the first amendment values and the
all those
high matters that this this case has
has come to to be involved with and to
in some way represent
um what i was struck with was the degree
of personal friendship
um and warmth that came from the
president and
in a way that's more important than all
the fine words and high principles
because
the thing that i look have looked for
when meeting politicians is not
how well they speak but how much passion
for the case they have
and and one of the things that was
remarkable about today's meetings was
that
not only the president but also mr lake
also mr christopher and the other
advisers who were there
seem to have genuine passion and
commitment for this case and
i take that to be of greater value than
than than all the
the words that we can bash out and all
the statements that we can issue because
it seems to me that it means that the
americans are serious about this
um and and that's a
a major development in this case because
the world being what it is at the moment
the world looks to the united states to
give a lead
i have no que no doubt in my mind that
this will send a message around the
world
and your presence here signifies that
you that you feel that too
um i have no doubt that it will
strengthen the resolve
of of our allies and so confusion
amongst our enemies
and i'm deeply grateful to the united
states uh through its leadership
through the president for having made
that possible i only want to say one
other thing which is that this is not
just a story of one writer in trouble
um the reason why i think the reason why
you are here the reason why these
ladies and gentlemen on this platform
are here the reason why we've been
fighting on this
for this case for so long is precisely
that it is about
it has become by accident a
representative of other cases
um in the last month in in in paris
100 of the most important intellectuals
of the muslim world
uh published jointly a book um
expressing solidarity with not just with
me but with this case
and with the values and and freedoms
that this case is about
these intellectuals include literally
every major writer and thinker in the
muslim world from najib mafus
to the poet adonis to to all the major
writers that you would have heard of
and it knocks on the head once and for
all
the untruth that the iranians have tried
to create
about this issue which is that it is
somehow is an issue about
islam versus the west this has nothing
to do
with islam versus the west and it was
something actually which in the meeting
today
the high officials that i met with were
at pains to emphasize they did not see
their support for me
as somehow anti-islamic
it's quite plain that what is actually
happening is a great struggle
inside muslim culture between its best
and worst voices between the kinds of
writers who signed this
uh who joined in this this statement in
paris
and the kinds of forces represented by
the ayatollah khomeini between the
progressive voice of islam
the need in that culture to develop a
modernizing secularizing face
and the worst most medievalist most
violent face of that culture
this is a war of great importance not
just in muslim countries but a war for
the world
and one in which it's very important
that western
countries begin to support the right
side begin to understand
that there is a progressive voice that
needs help that needs understanding that
needs foregrounding and needs support
and one should and and and the western
countries should not make the mistake
of identifying the worst face of islam
as its normal face it would it's a
mistake to see torquemada as the face of
christianity is an equivalent mistake to
see romania as the face of islam
i think it's it's it's important
therefore the united states government
has not just recognized
in me and in this case an issue about
western liberties and western freedoms
although clearly those are important
it's it's but that what the united
states government has also done is to
give its support to those modernizing
and progressive
aspects of the struggle inside muslim
culture and i think that's a very
positive
and democratic move um i think at this
stage that's all i'd like to say and now
i would happily answer
questions yes
what if anything did the u.s officials
the president the others
pledged to do in support of your uh
case will they make entreaties to iran
uh what specifically did they say well i
i gather in the first place that there
are statements fourth coming from
from the white house and i'm sure that
that i haven't actually seen those yet
but but i'm sure those will answer some
of the questions
we discussed a whole range of possible
policy
options of ways in which
the american administration could work
with
european partners through international
institutions
through multilateral forums uh to
increase the pressure on the government
of iran um i think there's no doubt that
this meeting itself is a political act
that's to say the fact of the meeting
itself is an act of pressure
and i think will be seen as such and
will be of great potency
in that regard in terms of detailed
policy it's probably best not to spell
out too much here because it's it's best
to let these things happen
in the way that's most effective i have
no doubt that the american government
was very committed to this case
and and uh agreed
with me that this was now a major item
on their agenda with iran and that
it was something that was a cause for
them
and in this in this regard one of the
things that i
suggested to them and that they were
happy to to agree with
was that that it's important to say that
many other people in the united states
have fought a battle of principle for
five years now
a number of ordinary employees of
publishing companies and the staff of
booksellers
and around the united states have been
in the front line
of the attempt to make sure that that
these freedoms and these rights
were safeguarded and i said that i hope
very much
the american administration be able to
express its appreciation of those people
and
they and they agreed with that in terms
of international pressure well we now
have a situation where the most powerful
country in the democratic world has
expressed
a major concern for this case and it is
quite clear
that the iranian government and the
terrorists at its disposal will not be
able to find a way around
that last year when i was in the united
states i met with a number of
very senior diplomatic figures and one
of them said to me
something which i've always remembered
he said he said the art of politics
is to be standing in the station when
the train arrives
he said if you're not standing in the
station don't be don't complain if you
miss the train
um the problem with any political issue
is that the train can arrive at a very
large number of different stations
you've somehow got to be arranged to be
standing in all of them
what we've been trying to do through the
rushdie defense campaign both
in in uh through article 19 in britain
and now through the american defense
campaign and other such defense groups
around europe
is to make sure that we are standing in
all those stations
i think what happened today is that we
just managed to get a very
sort of prime position in the most
important station of all
yes sir a group of
exiled iranian intellectuals including
writers actors and well-known
painters they signed a letter in which
they've expressed their support for you
and they've condemned the death sentence
against you
it was initiated by an iranian lady who
lives in exile in paris ms amisha who is
a writer
have you seen this letter have you read
this letter and what do you think of it
yes of course i've seen the letter and i
i'm well i've been in
contact with mashida meshahi and
just to update you since the letter
first appeared last year it reappeared
in
in a form this year in which instead of
56 or so people though there are now 200
or so people
signing it again the most important
intellectuals and
uh and writers and poets philosophers in
from iran
i mean clearly i appreciated it very
much it was an act of courage
um because although these writers are
and thinkers are mostly in exile
one of the things we have seen in recent
years is that exile does not protect you
the since the election of the so-called
moderate president rafsanjani
there have been i believe 21 or 22
political assassinations carried out by
iran in western europe
against against iranian dissidents so
these are people in
in constant danger even though they live
in in apparently free societies
so of course for them to to speak up as
they did was a matter of great
courage and i recognized it as an act of
great importance
and the the recent statement of the the
broader group of
of of muslim and arab intellectuals it
builds on that
um and i think just removes any figment
of pretense as i was saying
that iran tries to say that this is you
know one billion muslims are annoyed
about the satanic verses
well actually with almost no exceptions
that the muslims that i've come into
contact with
are annoyed about the iranian fatwa
which they know
demeans them uh which they know creates
a an untruthful and ugly image of them
in the world and which is the true
blasphemy
and that's to say where in islam does it
say that a man can be killed for writing
a book
uh that's a it's a it's a grotesque
bastardization
of what's supposed to be uh and like any
religion
and an encapsulation of the high values
of a society
this is a low and degraded um
bastardization of those values and i
think most muslims see it and when the
iranians
intellectuals spoke like that it was
clear proof of that
yes um have you ever uh challenged
iranian government to be more specific
uh because it's a blank statement
calling the book blasphemous
and all that but have you ever asked
what is it
exactly in what chapter in what verse
that
they have the most objection to and why
well
no i haven't i've taken the view that i
do not
look towards the iranian government for
literary criticism
that's you know that's my view um call
me foolish
uh it it seems to me that that they
never read the book
that that the particular charge against
the book anyway varies one day it's
blasphemy another day it's heresy in
other days apostasy another day it's
unisla on islamic behavior
as the wind blows so the attack changes
um
the fact is that this has never been
either a literary or a theological
matter
it's it's been a political stunt
and one of the the only advantage of
something going on for a very long time
is that people begin to see it for what
it is i i think when this first began
the fact that there was a kind of
religious cloak around this
terrorist act um confused people
and people were anxious not to offend
against people's sanctities and so forth
and therefore
began to use remarks such as there's no
smoke without fire and
all that and you know you must have
known what he was doing and he obviously
did it on purpose and etc
as if it was all right suddenly
to sanction the murder of somebody
because he upsets you um
one of the things that's happened during
the course of the last five years is
that it's become quite clear
and and as earlier questioners have
suggested the statements by other
muslims and other writers and
intellectuals have made it clear
that this just actually doesn't have
anything to do with with islam it has to
do
with a desire at a certain moment in
iran
of people to to seize an issue that
could re-energize the flagging radical
cause
and it's quite clear and i've seen it
printed in american reports
from iran that the iranians even admit
that the ayatollah never saw the sataric
verses and we never even saw a copy of
it
so so no i don't inquire of them which
pieces of the book they don't like i
have a strong suspicion which piece of
the book they might not like if they
read it
yes sorry can you tell us first a little
more about your conversation with mr
clinton
whether you discussed any of your books
and second
can you tell us your view of what has
changed in the 20 months since the bush
administration chose not to make any of
its officials available to you
well the the conversation of the
president was
was was not a detailed substantive
conversation because that's the one that
we had with mr lake and mr christopher
um as as i've indicated he was extremely
friendly towards me he said he was very
pleased
to meet me at last and mentioned the
various
friends we have in common i think he
particularly
referred to the interventions of the the
writers william styron and norman mela
on my behalf um william styron within
recent weeks when he was
uh invited to a banquet when he won an
honor at the white house
and norman mailer actually within the
last couple of days
and i would like to take this
opportunity to thank those writers and
and
apart from their many many other people
who have been engaged behind the scenes
in trying to make this event happen um
so you know we chatted about about about
bill and norman
and books and we talked about
about all sorts of little literary
things um
and and he was as i say the thing that
was really striking to me about the
meeting was
the real friendship and warmth that he
showed he thought francis de souza was
my lawyer
i'm not sure why he thought i'd brought
a lawyer to the meeting
but he was rapidly disabused of that
and he did say i think that i thought
was very valuable
that one of the things he found
important in this was
that it was in this case was that to
support this case was to show
america's commitment to spreading the
kind of freedoms
enshrined in the first amendment around
the world
and i think that was it's an important
remark because
it's a way of demonstrating that this is
not just
a problem happening to a writer from
another country
but that it is a it is an issue which
enshrines
those principles which are closest to
the american
public and at the heart of the american
constitution
and i thought it was very shrewd and
precise of him to to choose that
as as his point of focus for the change
since your last visit to washington
well uh well i didn't get very close to
the white house last time
i must say however that one of the
things that i've tried to do
throughout these this account these
years of campaigning
is to say that this is not a party
political issue
and i think everywhere we've been we
have tried to meet with
politicians of the right and the left
and the center and every other part of
the spectrum
and certainly when i was last in
washington that was the case
um i was i had a hosted for me a very
pleasant
lunch on on the hill and and met with a
group of senators and very senior
figures of both parties so
in that sense there was no division
between the parties at that level
um the bush administration was not
welcoming
and it's particularly heartening that
the position of the u.s government chain
has changed so fast
since the change of administration there
was already in i think january this year
a very strong statement made by the
president through mr stephanopoulos at
that time
um expressing the united states concern
and involvement with this case
engagement with this case and the thing
about today
is that in that respect today does not
report
today does not represent a new policy
because it seems to be the new policy
emerged
when that statement was made in january
what today
is in my mind is the most dramatic
and public and effective affirmation of
that policy that one could have ever
hoped for
certainly when i went to the white house
today i wasn't expecting to meet the
president so the fact that he took time
to do that
uh shows the the value that he places on
supporting uh this particular
free speech issue yes yeah last month
british air said they would
did not want to sell you a ticket on an
airplane
uh how did you ever work that out or
well the position with british airways
is unchanged
um i hope that we will be able to work
it out it's clearly
i said you understand that if your next
question is how did i get here i'm not
going to answer it
because we have always observed the
policy of confidentiality with all the
people that we carry and one of the
arguments i've been trying to make to
british airways is that lots of people
do it so what's their problem
in my view the problem that they have
has nothing to do with with safety
it's an entirely venal and commercial
problem to do with trying to safeguard a
route to terror
i'm this is not just my view the british
foreign office has
publicly stated that they do not share
british airways analysis of the threat
uh the british security forces say the
same thing
so we find ourselves in a ridiculous
situation where the people whose
professional job it is to assess the
threat
say there's no problem but the airline
pretends that there is and that seems to
me to suggest that the problem is
actually different
i think it's very i hope that actually i
hope that this meeting
the demonstration of support at this
level from let's say from the leader of
the free world
might demonstrate to this airline that
what they're doing is not only
dishonest because they're because
they're presenting
a reason which is not the true reason
but also immoral because
in fact in practice what it means is
they are joining forces with those who
seek to impose the iranian fatwa
and they become the fellow travelers of
terrorism and i think for an airline to
do that
is particularly reprehensible yes
um mr rushdie you you've now as it were
reached the pinnacle
of political support you've had the
personal display of support from prime
minister john major
from president bill clinton you've had
the support of
of writers from around the world you've
had the support of islamic intellectuals
what other levers can you possibly apply
for a remedy at this point and are we
not at the
at the at the case now where the
the if they do not respond to this
support from the white house
that the only hope that you will then
have will be for a change of regime in
iraq
well yes to well to answer the last part
the question first i do
hope for a change of regime in iran but
that's for other reasons
or not only for this reason but it's
also for the sake of the people of iran
the fact is that so far you're right
in saying that we have been trying to
achieve a certain level of political
support and i think that this is
a kind of pinnacle and i think this is
something we have worked towards
for this entire period of time and so it
does represent
uh certainly the highest point of the
campaign
the point i would make is that the
moment of achieving support
is not the moment at which the lever is
exercised that's the moment at which you
acquire the use of the lever
and what's happened today is the
american government has said that it is
prepared
to use its influence and power in this
case
that's what happened it hasn't actually
used it yet
but i do think that what i i have felt
for some time
is that i really do not feel like
spending the rest of my life being a
kind of traveling sideshow
um i think we've now reached a point at
which the major governments of the
democratic world
have taken this case on board have have
committed themselves to it as a policy
matter and in my view it's a little bit
it's over to them
if this matter is going to be solved it
will be solved because the international
community does exercise the leverage of
which you speak
um we shall see and i think that there's
what i can do
is to ask them for their help and to
gain their commitment
to help and that's what up to now we've
been doing
i think i do think we've now reached a
point where more or less we've got we've
got
that those assurances and now i think in
the next phase of this campaign
we shall see what those assurances are
worth
yes sir uh but given the factionalism
and and many
radical groups within the muslim
community do you think you'll be ever be
safe even if the iranians do have a
change of heart on this
well i'll tell you i mean it's a good
question
and don't think it doesn't occur to me
um
but the truth is that in the last five
years
every time i have become aware of being
made aware
of a serious threat every time
it has been a threat engineered by the
government of iran
directly through its through agencies of
the government and its embassies abroad
and through the hire of professional
killers
that has been a recurring theme i'm
afraid to say during the last five years
there have been several moments when
i have received intelligence information
to that effect
there has never been an instance in
which
any other islamic body has shown any
interest in pursuing this matter
that's never as far as
the ordinary muslim community of britain
where i live and indeed of most other
countries that i'm aware of including
the united states
it's concerned they have never shown any
support
for the death threats many of them may
have been hostile towards me
that's not the matter they might not
like what i write that's their privilege
but none of them as far as i know except
for occasional
mountain banks with no support have ever
shown any interest in actually pursuing
the death threat
option so that the reason why the
campaign has focused on the issue of
state terrorism
is that is that actually that is what
has been the problem the problem is not
a generalized issue in the muslim world
it is problem of state terrorism
run by the government of iran and the
reason why what we're looking for
is to see iran publicly and accountably
renounce that option
is that after that yes you're quite
right there might be the occasional hot
head but
the the problem of
facing an occasional hothead is entirely
different
level of problem to the problem of
facing state terrorism
i would just like to say one thing which
is
again we're kind of falling into the
tendency of saying that it is only i who
am in danger
as as recent events have shown it is
very much not only i who i'm in danger
and one of the things you could say and
it's true is that as the presence in
this room of the
um the security forces indicates i am by
far the best protected person
threatened by the iranian fatwa um
i'd like just at this moment to speak
for a moment about my
courageous and very distinguished
norwegian publisher william nougat
who was who was shot in the back three
times by 44 caliber bullets
and appears to have to escaped by a kind
of miracle and will make a full recovery
but
that's no thanks to his would-be
assassin i mean there's a demonstration
that there are principled people
brave people and just ordinary people
working in publishing and book selling
and printing
around the world who could at any moment
be attacked
and it is not only my safety that i'm
looking to safeguard here but it is the
safety of
of all those people and not only of all
those people but of all those people
involved in other similar cases
who say when they are asked that the
rushdie case is their fight too
when intellectuals in in arab countries
muslim countries have been approached by
western academics and journalists in
recent in recent
times they say you must defend rusli
because if you don't defend rishi you do
not defend us
the iranian intellectuals that we
mentioned earlier uh
said quite clearly that they are right i
think that the real attack that the
fatwa launches is against
iranian dissidents because what it says
is
that if rushdie a citizen of a free
country has to live in this way
you know imagine what would happen to
you if you dared to stand up and say
something we did not approve of so
so this is a fight not just for one
individual but for many many people and
for many
uh for many different causes which ally
behind this one
yes sorry at the back version uh sir
would you please uh you said something a
couple minutes ago about
what you learned from uh intelligence
sources yeah would you kind of
demonstrate
uh you know how you get this
intelligence information
and indeed if if 22 persons have been
assassinated yeah
with iranian government support our
complicity
or or dictation by the iranian
government how do you come to know these
things
oh well these are the to take the second
question first that's a matter of public
record i mean it's it's uh
these are all assassinations that have
happened in western europe in the last
few years
and have been reported in the press and
the police forces of the relevant
countries
are the ones who have pointed the finger
towards iran involvement so this is
this is not something that that i uh
simply speculate about it's a it's a
matter of public record and can be
can be checked um the attacks on
in my in this case the the attack on the
italian translator the satanic verses uh
two years ago
was carried out by a man who said
himself that he came from the iranian
embassy
when the iranian embassy was asked about
this they answered fearlessly
no comment the japanese
uh translator of the static versus who
was murdered
um it the japanese police said after a
12-month investigation that they had
uh strong evidence that assassins had
entered
uh japan from from via china from the
middle east
and they had identified
the work names of at least two known
middle eastern terrorist personnel
and it doesn't take a genius to know who
is the major financier of those
of those which country is the major
financier of those terrorist
factions um so so that
these matters are are matters of of
record and
uh they're not um they're not opinions
um i'm sorry the first part of your
question i i forget
how you how you get intelligence
information i thought a job that the
security people were doing for you was
protecting you not
giving you no well that's true i'm
obviously given
information strictly on need to know
basis and i'm always given it
in a rather vague form but there are
there are and actually when i'm given it
in a less than vague form i think it'd
be improper of me to make it precise
in this place but there are there are
again
things that are matters of public record
um
i think just over a year ago about 15
months ago
francis will correct me if i'm wrong the
british government expelled
from britain three iranian citizens
two of whom were staff
at the iranian mission in london and the
third of whom
was an iranian student who had entered
britain on an iranian
state scholarship and i had a briefing
meeting
with the foreign office at which they
said to me that in their view there was
no doubt
that these three were all iranian
intelligence agents and were in britain
at least partly you know in
in for reasons related to the
carrying out to the main fatwa so during
the last five years
that there have been other expulsions of
iranian
citizens from britain and in many of
those cases it was made plain that the
reason for those expulsions was
uh was a connection to this this case so
i think those things i can say to you
because they're already in the public
domain
uh there are others which i'm obliged to
remain silent about
yes i'm sorry yes you uh had some praise
for the publishing community
are you satisfied now that they will
handle your books without restraint or
without fear or
can you characterize how much restraint
you feel that they will exercise
oh i think the publishing community on
the whole
has been fantastically principled
um and carried on with
the publication of satanic verses
against
extraordinary odds i mean i've i've said
throughout this that
that um the original publishers
of the satanic verses and remember that
the static verses was originally an
american publication
um that that uh viking penguins courage
in holding the line at the moment
of maximum danger i think is it is
absolutely
exemplary and they deserve enormous
amounts of praise for having done that
um the fact that the payback was then
published by a consortium
is was also further demonstration of of
a kind of broad-based solidarity for
for the right to publish um
and as far as future publishing is
concerned well i've i've published two
and a half books since the satanic
verses
um i've published a novel and a volume
of essays and a short monograph
and and all of them were published in a
perfectly ordinary publishing way and
and no
uh difficulty accrued to any of those
publications actually no difficulty
was involved in the publication the
paperback static purchases um
exactly as i suspected the moment the
iranian money dried up there were no
demonstrations
and um the book simply was published
like a paperback and and exists in the
marketplace as the as any other book
also i had published a number of books
before the satanic verses which
all remained widely in print during the
entire um fuss and still remain in print
and no trouble has ever uh
happened around those publications
either so so
i would i think the publishing community
is well aware of that and i don't expect
any problem with future publication
affected you as yes writer well
i mean clearly it has you know i mean it
would be i'd be a very bad writer if it
did not
um because anything that happens over a
period of five years of your life
affects you as a writer
exactly how it's very difficult for me
to articulate
it's probably easier for readers to
articulate than i but
i will say this that i've published one
novel
since the satanic verses and it was the
most optimistic
and cheerful novel i've ever written um
so
you could say that the last five years
have made me a more optimistic and
cheerful writer
um that novel harun in the sea of
stories is my
first successful attempt at creating a
happy ending
in a novel and i suspect it was partly
because as a writer i'd become
deeply interested in happy endings and i
thought i would try and construct one
so having constructed one there i'm i'm
now trying to construct one here and
uh again i'm grateful to president
clinton and the others at the white
house today for helping in that search
but
beyond that i can't say i think you know
you'll have to read the books and tell
me
yes i have a rather personal question
given the fact that you are the target
of uh
fundamental muslims how do you spend
your daily life
what do you do do you get ever
frustrated
oh well sure there are great
frustrations in the situation
and there and there are great
limitations on on my movements and so on
you know but
but i mean i've been trying to improve
that situation and to to reduce those
those limitations and to an extent have
succeeded
um my greatest frustration is very
simple it's that
the people that i have always drawn my
inspiration from and written about
have been given a very false impression
of the kind of writer that i am
and i have wanted very
often to try and say to them i'm not
like that i'm like this
unfortunately my voice is not loud
enough
um uh because the because i don't have
the services of
half the pulpits of half the mosques in
the world
um i find that distortion that
uh by far the most distressing aspect
of this and for a long time it used to
upset me profoundly that the book
that you know every taxi driver in cairo
would have an opinion about
the satanic verses um but that virtually
nobody would have read it
and it then occurred to me as a small
consolation that that
many of the persecutions of famous
persecutions of books
are carried out have been carried out by
people who never read the book
um it's impossible to believe that those
who
accuse joyce of of of blasphemy and
pornography and so forth had ever read
ulysses um it's it's improbable in my
mind
that um those who attacked um nabokov
for being a child molester had much
knowledge of
the content of lolita um it seems
well we know that that's that um those
who
set themselves up against lady
chatterley uh had very little
knowledge of the content of that book so
so at least
at least i'm in in good company it seems
that it is necessary not to read a book
in order to become able to burn it and
to seek the death of its author
um but i am i am distressed about the
the
the false portrait of my personality
indeed of my work
that that obtains in many muslim
countries and can only hope that the
kinds of small steps now being taken by
by my colleagues in the literary and
intellectual community may slowly change
that
yes um i myself and colleagues are from
voice of america so naturally this
will be aired throughout the world but
specifically we'll be
broadcasting that to iran in translation
so given that fact that this is a direct
link
if there's anything you would like to
add to what you have already said
oh i i think i i don't i actually don't
have a great deal to say to president
rafsanjani or to the ayatollah
except in very simple terms
they're wrong and it seems to me that
they should understand
that this issue will not fade away i
think the iranian gamble
is that if they just hang in there in
the end
nobody is going to go on and on worrying
about the rights of one individual and
and and you know business as usual will
gradually be resumed
um what this campaign has been about is
to demonstrate to them that the opposite
of that
is what is happening that instead of
the issue fading away that the issue is
getting more and more and more
prominent and of course the support of
the of the american administration today
is the most
obvious and emphatic demonstration of
that fact
so i would say to the iranian government
for their
own self-interest they had better think
hard about changing their position
because they are damaging their own
interests very considerably and they may
shortly discover that
they are damaging them even more than
they think
yes talking about the the sound of your
voice and the loudness of your voice it
seems to me though
that you're not only talking to the
iranian government or the persons who
who put the fatwa on you uh you're also
taking the case of uh
conditions of of of writers and artists
in in conservative arab countries
and you're also likening yourself to uh
to joyce
and to and to other writers i wonder if
um
in talking about the loudness of your
voice are you are you that same moderate
person who began as a writer or are you
um are you some great symbol
oh well i don't feel very symbolic i
have to say it's difficult
to feel as good as say i feel i feel not
metaphoric but naturalistic
i feel that almost social realistic
that's it um no i mean i think when i
liken myself to joyce though i don't do
so in terms of genius i do so only in
terms of the trouble
we're in and actually he may be a
greater writer than me but i'm in more
trouble than him
so only in that sense um
i think there is there is no doubt that
i
i mean by by inclination i was a comic
satirical writer
it's one of the things that is very
difficult for such writers who
who who exist mainly by defining
themselves in terms of what they're
against
is to is to find themselves in a kind of
life situation where they have to define
themselves in terms of what they're for
and yet it became clear to me very early
in this that if one was going to fight
this fight it was not
it's very easy to say what i'm against
in this situation you know i'm i'm
against
state terrorism i'm against the
persecution of people for the expression
of their ideas i think that's these are
easy
against the government of iran and
that's easy the question is what is one
for
and and i have felt that if i'm afforded
this platform
by this bizarre situation then
it would be obscene of me to stand here
and say
look at me or only to say look at me and
it gives me an opportunity to talk
about persecutions happening elsewhere
which otherwise
you would not be here to listen to such
stories
you know i mean if one was to talk about
if i were not here to mention the case
of the algerian writer tara joad who was
assassinated by fundamentalists
earlier this year or the case of the
egyptian intellectual farage food who
was assassinated by fundamentalists just
over a year ago
or the case of the turkish journalist
ogur mumchu who was shot by religious
fundamentalists earlier this year
or the case of the bangladeshi writer
taslima nasrin who is now living under a
death threat
in bangladesh with the price on her head
or the many many other cases i have at
least
the ability to say listen to what's
happening
you know it is not just happening to me
it is happening all over the world
and you and if we do not look at it we
allow it to happen
uh so we can either be complicit in it
or we can fight against it
and and that is much more important than
the life of salman rusli
it really is yes
are you satisfying muslim intellectuals
show support am i satisfied with muslim
intellectuals
i'm getting more satisfied i mean i
think there was a long time when it was
my greatest disappointment
that a lot of muslim intellectuals kept
quiet um i think there are obvious
reasons for that which have to do with
with with the degree of intimidation in
the countries in which they live
and i mean i don't blame them for it but
i regretted it
um i i think that the increasing courage
of academics writers and intellectuals
in the muslim world to speak up about
this issue
is actually in recent months one of the
most gratifying things that's happened
and yes i think if that is that if
that's it then
again i mean thank you all for coming
and um happy thanksgiving
three minutes
you